get ready for more gym tan and laundry  because Snooki just teased a Jersey  Shore reunion on Friday the reality star  shared the good news on Instagram  posting this video of her with her  former castmates rocking out in a car  [Music]  yep that's Mike the situation DJ Pauly D  Sammi Sweetheart and JWoww the 29 year  olds captioned the clip quotes it's  happening guys August 20th love my  roomies forever  hashtag jurors day is here this is a  situation situation right  shortly after Snooki T is the reboot she  might just the way you pictured me just  the way I remembered accepter tanner an  official sneak peak of reunion road trip  returned to the Jersey Shore was  released and it promises some major  Jersey filled the show will follow the  Jersey crew five years after they left  the shore  Jim is now Jim in my home Tanning's now  spray tanning and lovely nice ended up  and it's sure to be a fist pumping good  time yeah buddy  [Music]